aujourd'hui je suis conseillère
municipale de la ville de lyon et donc
c'est dans le prolongement de cet
engagement ça me semble aujourd'hui
naturel d'être candidate pour les
législatives sur la troisième circuit du
rhône aujourd'hui je m'engage sous
l'étiquette de la droite et du centre
pour moi c'est vraiment important pour
le débat démocratique que nous soyons
présents à l'assemblée nationale je
défendrai les valeurs qui sont les
miennes et qui sont celles des
républicains la liberté la
responsabilité je crois profondément en
la dignité par le travail voilà sur
toutes ces valeurs que je défendrai
autre chose d'important pour moi c'est
la transmission je pense que nous sommes
les héritiers d'un passé et aujourd'hui
moi j'ai envie d'être actrice dans le
présent pour l'avenir